christmas is just around the corner and
every year I spend days on the internet
looking for some good tech gifts to buy
for my loved ones this year I've decided
to take it up a notch and actually make
my own list of the top 5 tech gifts in
2019
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas and welcome back to the channel
like I mentioned today we're talking
about the top 5 tech gifts you could go
out and buy for one of your loved ones
or potentially even for yourself today's
list is actually going to be a little
bit different to everybody else's I'm
not just gonna give you guys a list of
the best 5 things I'm also going to go
ahead and give you a list of the
categories first and then break down
some different price options in these
categories everything that I mentioned
in this video today guys I'm gonna link
it down below so you can find it for
quick reference I'm in no way shape or
form
sponsored by Amazon or paid by Amazon so
anything that you click on isn't gonna
make me any money it's just really for
you guys to be able to find the quickest
reference for everything I'm talking
about so without further ado let's dive
straight into this list for the top 5
tech gifts in 2019 so the number one
item is a small smart speaker for one
reason is because they're relatively
cheap for example you can pick up a
Google home Mini in Australia for under
$50 that's something like 30 American
dollars which most families can afford
and they're a great little gift I use my
little google speaker almost every
single day be it for listening to music
ask me about the weather even just
asking what time it is it's actually
just a really handy little device to
have around the home so for me the
Google home and the Google home Mini are
the best choice in this little category
because they provide really good quality
sound and really good AI assistance
without being too over priced but if
you're not a Google person and you want
something a little bit different Amazon
Alexa is also a great little product
there's also the option of the Amazon
echo which is the cheaper version of
Amazon's Alexa the same way you have the
Google home Mini and you have the Google
home you have the Amazon
eko and you have Amazon's Alexa devices
the good thing about Amazon Alexa is a
simple fact that it's actually not
controlled by one of the key parties
controlling the smartphone game Google
for instance has its own Google pixel
line and it control is a pretty decent
share of the smartphone game whereas
Amazon so far today doesn't have any
major stakeholders in this industry so
they're staying pretty neutral and
pretty compatible with all the
smartphones on the market as a
standalone competitor you can also go to
products like boasts Sonos Sony or even
one of these really cool lamp I don't
know I don't really know what's
described it as it's a lamp cross
wireless charger across smart speaker
but it's just some random little smart
speaker I found on Amazon for about a
hundred and fifty dollars I think it was
Australian and it's just some cool
little quirky device it does everything
in one and for a pretty good price I
have no idea what the sounds like I have
no idea about the quality I just thought
it was good design that's worth chucking
into this video second item on my top 5
Christmas list of tech gifts in 2019 is
a very small drone now if you're
familiar to the drone market you know
the drone I'm talking about it's the DJI
Mavic mini which has been compared in
size to the iPhone 11 pro max so
straight away this is going to tell you
that this drone is tiny weighing only
249 grams and coming in at 600
Australian dollars this isn't exactly a
drawing that everybody can go out and
buy it is still pretty expensive but it
is a very good intro drone if you're
looking at getting into drone
photography drone videography or just to
have some fun with some dragons if you
don't have $600 to spend on the DJI
maverick mini well then there is another
option that I do recommend and it is
staying within the DJI product line the
reason I say stay in the DJI product
line is for the simple fact that they
are the leaders in drone technology they
do drones really well and they
manufacture them really well so if
you're looking for something a little
bit cheaper think about the DJI
Tello it comes in at about a hundred
Australian dollars and is the perfect
indoor intro drone for anybody who's
looking to get a drone in this Christmas
so number three on my list is a set of
wireless headphones if you guys haven't
noticed people wearing wireless
headphones around the street around the
gym or anywhere you might be going
outside well then you probably haven't
actually been paying enough attention
wireless headphones are becoming a huge
trend especially in ear wireless
headphones in 2019 for example apples
air pods have sold over a hundred
million units this year alone that
grosses out at something close to one
hundred and seventy five billion dollars
in just headphone sales so if you're
looking at getting somebody a pair of
wireless headphones or a pair of
wireless in ear headphones well then I
think it really depends on what kind of
device they're using both for Apple
earpods
and Galaxy buds phenomenal devices I
personally used Galaxy buds because I'm
a Samsung person but I do also have a
set of the air pods at home that I've
tried and tested they're both phenomenal
devices one of the best things about air
pods or Galaxy bugs for Christmas is
they come in the most inconspicuous
little box and nobody and I mean nobody
is actually gonna be able to guess what
it is in the wrapping underneath the
tree coming in at number four on my list
today is something that's starting to
take over our lives and that I believe
is smartwatches
there are a ton of different SmartWatch
options on the market moment but I think
my personal opinion there's only two
real main competitors you have the Apple
watch series five and you have also the
Samsung Galaxy active two I did a
comparison on these I'll link it up if I
remember to put this in this video but
both devices are really really good they
do come in a pretty hefty price tag
that's why I say there's many other
options on the market that I think you
really should look into if you're
looking at a Smart Watch for Christmas
this year
I know fitbit's do some great devices
and Garmin do some even more
Apple ones than either of these two
options but again Garmin steps to the
price up a little bit whereas Fitbit you
can pick up for a little bit cheaper
last but not least on my list of tech
gifts in 2019 for Christmas is a
portable tablet I think the main being
in the tech industry and the tech space
buying a tablet is a very personal
choice I think it really depends on what
kind of lifestyle you have and what
you're planning on using it for on the
other hand and I think it really matters
if you're an Apple person or a Samsung
person and when it comes to buying a
tablet it really depends on your
lifestyle and what you're planning on
using it for if you're an Apple person
well then that's a little bit of a bonus
for you guys today the number one tablet
on my list in 2019 is the brand new
Apple iPad Mini this device is so handy
so nimble so compact comes with an
impressive screen resolution and an even
more impressive
battery life which is just unbeatable as
well as the price itself that always
goes on special around the world that
you can pick it up for a relatively
cheap and get a phenomenal device at the
end of the day you can pick up a Samsung
Tab A for a lot lot cheaper than an
Apple iPad Mini but in my experience I
know that these tablets after a year
start to lag after a couple years start
to break down and you have to repair
them or replace them these things yes
they're really good they're really cheap
for a little while but if you're looking
to have a tablet that's gonna last a lot
longer my personal experience points me
towards the Apple devices my final piece
of advice for you guys today before I
sign off is basically don't cheap out on
tech there's a reason why tech cost so
much and there is a reason why cheap
tech is cheap tech don't go on eBay and
buy a knockoff brand of what you really
want it might cost you an extra fifty
hundred dollars but I can guarantee you
that 50 to 100 dollars is definitely
worth it
buying a knockoff brand is only gonna
lead to headaches misery and potentially
just a very very big hole in your pocket
for no reason whatsoever if you have the
ability to go out to a physical store
and buy it from a physical store where
you can
eventually return it if something goes
wrong while it's under the warranty
period this is also highly recommended
having to go online and deal with online
customer service or over the phone
customer service for almost every single
company is actually a huge burden so if
you can go to the shops to Harvey Norman
JB hi-fi if you're in Australia
definitely go to those guys definitely
buy them from them direct if you can't
well if it's unavoidable then obviously
it grabbed one from online and you may
find a better price as well that's all
for me guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed my top 5
tech gifts for Christmas in 2019 if you
haven't already make sure you smash that
subscribe button
20:19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday